[Music]
so here we are with news about Godzilla
the monsterverse more specifically about
Monarch the legacy of monsters a bit on
minus one and what the near future holds
for us so we will list them out
pointwise I always like them simplified
in points rather than just jumble up I
don't know maybe it's just me so let's
get to it firstly New York ComiCon to
feature an entire episode of legacy of
monsters in the Empire stage yep you
heard me right boys Godzilla and the
Titans will be showcased live in New
York City ComicCon this 13th of October
and maybe for others who will see the
video after the date just know that
there are people lucky enough who would
have seen the first episode of the
series in a test screening to see how
the public will react to the upcoming
show number two a new trailer to follow
the teaser trailer that was released
last month yeah with the show stated to
be released on November 17th which puts
it just a month away and with the added
information that they will be showcasing
the first episode in ComicCon we are
bound to get our heads blown off with a
new full trailer for the series in the
coming week or maybe even sooner but you
know what Apple does they put out a full
trailer a month before the series end
air so high hopes number three creation
of new tirant that will rival Godzilla
and Kong in the future so Matt shakman
the director of two episodes hints at
the possibility of unveiling new talant
in the series while discussing the show
he teases the creation of new monsters
for the monsterverse and suggest new
surprises ahead shakman Still Remains
tight lied to maintain secrecy and to
maintain his own excitement but
emphasizes the inclusion of familiar
characters alongside the introduction of
new fresh tirans ones that might rival
and maybe even replace the two tit
monsters as the cream of the
universe number four probable spin-off
series for the Titans and also a sequel
for legacy of monsters well it all
depends on the potential success of the
series and it could lead to the creation
of iconic Titans that will rival the
likes of Godzilla and King Kong as
shakman hinted it seems all but certain
that Monarch the legacy of monsters will
feature tents never before seen within
that Universe this could lead to
additional projects within that
franchise as they Pioneer and feature
stories considering how these beings
came to be their Origins and should the
series be successful then there will be
plans for another season and even
spin-off
series number five minus one will be
just over 2 hours long and it is 3 weeks
away yeah the Toho movie will be 125
minutes long all without the credit
scenes than just under 2 hours Godzilla
minus one is slated to Premiere at the
36th Tokyo International Film Festival
on November 1st serving as the closing
film and then released to Cinemas 2 days
later in America it will be December 1st
alongside Beyonce's documentary or
something I don't know gvb Godzilla
versus queen bee number six Godzilla
versus Kong versus the justice league is
just a week away so while Batman has had
a crossover with Kong in the Lego movies
Superman and the kaijus have never met
so on the 17th of October next week
Godzilla versus Kong versus the Justice
League will be issued out the comics
will have their first issue released but
you know we all just want to see the man
in blue versus the Titan in blue
Superman versus
Godzilla number seven a potential
jiujitsu kaisen X Godzilla collaboration
and crossover so the anime and manga
series Jutsu kaisen which delivers a
fresh collection of demons and monsters
will have their crossover collaboration
with Toho on Godzilla merge which will
include chibi Miniatures but this just
might very well lead to a future Cameo
of Godzilla in an episode or two in
their anime series just like how snow
Godzilla was seen in the shin Calon
show number eight Godzilla War for
Humanity Comics by IDW issue number two
is out so released last month this 27th
of September and now available to
everyone Godzilla War for human the
comics issue number two is out and it
has a juicy and new deadly Kaiju it will
also feature the fan favorite angiras as
well as mugera the robot SL mea and
Godzilla and even Mothra will have to
battle this new monster a mushroom funi
monster called
Zora number nine gxk the new Empire a
trailer this November or maybe another
teaser in ComiCon well we can only hope
can we but this might might not just be
blind hope and instead a calculated and
educated guess oh yeah with gxk the new
Empire slated for release this April
therefore we should be ready for a late
November release of a trailer and since
it has been quite a while since we saw
scar King in that 302nd teaser we might
just be lucky enough to see shimu or a
short teaser trailer for the new Empire
in New York
ComicCon
hoops and number 10 gxk the hunted new
images and the main plot revealed well
we have done a video about this one and
we know that many haven't seen it so
just to let you guys know gxk the hunted
has released quite a few Images new
images in a Kickstarter campaign for the
comics and as for the plot of the hunted
it goes like this a twisted Skull Island
Trophy Hunter baits his trap and sets
his sights on the biggest game of all
deep within the hollow Earth
so boys let's get ready for 6 months of
Monster Mania oh yeah so if you like
this video then watch this one as well
and if you're more interested in other
movie monsters and creatures then check
out our Channel we might just have a
thing or two that you haven't seen or
thought about like subscribe and we'll
see you on the next video take care fam